sie jagen meist in der dämmerung oder
nachts lautlos und dem rudel wölfe in
deutschland 300 tiere soll es geben
allein in brandenburg rund um berlin
tendenz steigend auch die bauern nacken
immer deutlicher dass der wolf zurück
ist die rudel leben wildtieren auch ihr
vieh auf den weiden
der wirtschaftliche schaden ist hoch für
den brandenburger landwirt jürgen
frenzel wegen der verluste durch den
wolf längst zur existenzfrage
die würfe während meiner meinung nach
hier schickte wir haben den eindruck
dass sie hingehen in die herde die herde
jagen und bei diesem jahr separieren sie
ein kalb 40 kälber habe er 2017 verloren
zehn mal so viel wie im jahr zuvor
entschädigung gibt es nur wenn der wolf
als täter eindeutig nachgewiesen wird
schwierig wenn kälber spurlos
verschwinden oder eine kuh ein junges
durch den stress tot zur welt bringt mit
zäunen sollen die bauern selbst für
schutz sorgen doch die investitionen
dafür sind hoch werden wir für unser
zwei herden mit insgesamt 180 tieren den
zaun so wolfs gerecht bauen wollen
müssen wir knapp 100000 euro investieren
und wir bekommen neuneinhalb 1000 euro
ersetzt dafür auf die verluste der
bauern hat brandenburg nun reagiert es
gibt die wölfe zum abschuss frei wenn
sie trotz aller schutzmaßnahmen sowie
bei jürgen frenzel mehrfach vier eines
bauern reißen oder gar einen menschen
angreifen dem wolf auf der spur sind
auch naturschützer stefan heuser
verfolgt seit jahren die entwicklung
eines rudels in seiner gegend und ist
überzeugt so dramatisch ist die
situation gar nicht und wenn der wolf
nicht durch futter gelockt werde meinte
er auch den menschen gesehen eine
frische wolfsfährte die es von netto
nachtlinie stunden alt
und jetzt ist in zehn jahren fünf sechs
mal passiert dass ich mal ansehen durfte
aber in der regel sind diese scheu sie
beobachten uns kann ich mir vorstellen
volker sieht sein rudel meist nur durch
die fotofallen mit denen er die wölfe
beobachtet drehte sich und die kamera
auslösen hat hören den blitz kann er
nicht sehen sind dort blitzt er halt
sehr vorsichtig die tiere müssten ihren
platz in brandenburg haben sagt der
naturschützer wölfe behörden erlaubnis
zu schießen das sei noch gar nicht nötig
und panikmache
eine art geschützte tierart die streng
unter schutz steht und bei den paar
würden die wir hier haben
man muss nicht immer alles hoch
multiplizieren und was hätte wäre wenn
einmal 30% zuwachsraten im jahr
ich kann nicht mehr werden so wir haben
es noch nicht wir haben nicht mal 1000
stück in deutschland nicht mal 1000
wölfe den meisten jägern ist das noch zu
viel
der brandenburger jagdverband fordert
strengere regeln das große raubtiere
passe nicht die moderne kulturlandschaft
nötig seien feste abschussquoten und
jäger wollen frei entscheiden wann ein
tier geschossen werden muss einigen
würde sogar nur ein einziges rudel in
einem deutschen reservat reichen und die
können dann nachhaltig leben die können
sie da ihre jungen großziehen die können
da raushalten und dann ich denke ich
dass eine gute sache und dürften
eigentlich auch allen gerecht werden und
wer dann mehr wölfe sehen will der soll
eine tory positionen die unvereinbar
sind mit den wünschen der tierschützer
im streit zwischen jägern bauern und
naturschutzverbänden droht eine wirksame
strategie für eine künftige ross
population auf der strecke zu bleiben
wir müssen weiter daran arbeiten das ist
besser wird auf jeden fall also wenn ich
sehe wie hier mit der er schafft
zusammen arbeiten kann ist ein
vorzeigeprojekt wird habe ich noch nicht
erlebt meist tritt man nur widerstand
und eiswürfel knallt die alle ab kann im
kopf schon vor 100 jahren wurden die
wölfe in deutschland vertrieben
die tiere natur und landschaft nun
wieder zu integrieren trotz der
dazugehörenden schäden
diese aufgabe kann nur der mensch
leisten